[音楽]
えっうん
苞木
me
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
今日は皆さんにアーキテクトになろうという話をします
とはいっても建築家になりましょうっていう話ではないので貼っ建築に関係ないよと
思っている人も
今日は何かも何かあるかもしれないと思って弾いてくれた嬉しいです
僕の大学時代は選考が建築でした
建築学科に入って一番最初に先生から教えてもらったことが飽きてきちゃう意味でした
生成が入ったのは秋 picture とはあらゆる技術
それを統合するそういったものだと
教えられました
大学で建築を学んだと口は建築設計の仕事につきました
建築設計の仕事をしていてその中で生まれた思いが
これ本当にあらゆる技術を統合する人つまりはアーキテクトに置くなりたいなとそう
思いました
そのためにはものづくりの技術がどういったものであるかをもっと僕自身がまあ学ぶ
必要があるとそう思いました
建築におけるモノづくりを
技術といえば現場で働いている
大工さんだったりとか職人さんだったりそういった人たちの仕事の中に
ヒントがあるとそう思ってそこに取り込もうと思いました
でも
like になるのはすぐに諦めました
見てわかるとおり
大工さんってすごいんですよ筋肉
で僕の筋肉があまりにも華奢すぎてこれは何かも誰かに細胞レベルから肉体改造をして
もらわない限り
大工にはなれないなあってすぐにひるんでしまって
諦めました
で
諦めたんですけどそんな中あるイベントで sfc の田中浩也先生に出会いました
建築家が集まるイベントだったんですけれども
なさる建築家を前にしてですね田中先生がおっしゃったのが
建築で解決できない問題があったら
それはウェブサイト1個作ったら解決するかもしれない
建築以外の店分野のテクノロジーを使ったら解決するかもしれない
そういったことをしてみなよと
そういったことをおっしゃいました
なんかすごいさらっと
発言されたんですけど僕にはすごくそれがぐっと刺さりまして
その当時田中先生が
新しく研究テーマとして取り組もうとしてたのが精神の皆さんならもうすでにご存じ
ファブ fab five でした
でほぼあらゆるものを作る方法である5
それは木にもう一度勇気を与えてくれました
ハードな筋トレをしなくてもアーキテクトになれる3し学校にあるかもしれないと
そう思って迷わず僕はまだ役員で sac に行ってきました
sc 大学中にまだ当時日本にはファブラボという施設がなかったんですけれどもそれ
を彫った皆で日本に作ろうよとそういったことを広める団体としてま有志団体のファブ
ラボジャパンというものを
は立ち上げてそこに僕も活動に参加をしました
でその活動の中で
クレーターのネットワークをオンライン上でぜ怪獣に持っている
ロフトワークという会社があるんですけれどもそこで祖母と一緒に神戸で
ワークショップしたんですね
その後僕は ssa koss じゃないですロフトワークにジョインしまして
そしてファブカフェを立ち上げることにしました
サブカフェは
誰でも初めて
羽生に取り組みプライできる
触れられるそういった場所です
興味関心にもかかわらず誰もが自由に出入りして
1でも学んでそういった場所であるためにはまた上であること常に開いているオープン
なを知られることが大切だと考えました
ファブカフェではにしよう的にいろいろな様々な
たようなコミュニティダーン発生してます
例えばレーザーカッターを使って建築のスタディーモデルをつくっている
建築設計者の人たち
3 d プリンターで出力した筐体をですね眺めながら議論しているプロダクトの園児
プロジェクターのデザイナーの人たち
そして仲間を集めたりとか自分のアイディアを共有したりとかそういったピッチ
イベントで集まっているエンジニアの皆さん
そして初めてハブにトライしようとする人が始めの一歩として踏み出す半蔵の勉強会が
行われていたり
そして仕事帰りに仲間で集まってリーダーを食べながらおしゃべりを楽しみながらそう
いった女子会みたいなものも行われています
まあ今いったシチュエーションが同時にこう発生するって瞬間はなかなかかなりレアな
シチュエーションではあるんですがそういったシチュエーションをどんどん起こして
ほしいと思って僕が普段羽生カフェのスタッフに言っていることがあります
それは今日この瞬間目の前で起こっている
二つの異なる事象をつなげることそれが photo cafe スタッフである
あなたの役割ですとそう言ってます
ファブカフェにはあらゆるコミュニティーがあるんですけれどもそういった目の前で
起こっていることを拾い上げて
つなげることそういったところから羽生壁が表がってきています
例えばカーデザイナーを初太刀のコミュニティがそこにあったら実に多くの大会を開催
してみようと
で細胞を研究する研究者のコミュニティーがあったら
バイオラボを設立してみよう
そして葉歩花庭の志に共感してくれる仲間が世界に見つかったら海外にも羽生カフェを
展開してみよう
そうしてグローバルにネットワークが増えてきたら
じゃあ今度はその世界中の拠点に集まるクレーターに向けたグローバルアワードを開催
してみようと
でこれらはもちろん僕らにとってすべて初めてのチャレンジでした
そういったつながりを作ることそして次のステップをデザインすることをそういった
ことの連続でファブカフェの
ファブカフェでは
ほぼあらゆるものを作ること方法パブ
からほぼあらゆるものを作るコミュニティーづくりその場を広げていっています
でファブカフェや最初渋谷の道玄坂の上ですね渋谷のど真ん中始まったんですけれども
国内2番目にできたアブカフェがまさかの日だという場所でした
なんでまさかっていうと渋谷のど真ん中でワイワイやってたのが急に好機だという場所
で始まるとは
僕自身全く思ってなかったですし周りにいるみんなも想像もしてなかったと
でも数年にわたりいろんな活動をしていく中で出会った人だったりとか
アイディアがその瞬間ある日強く結びつき
パブからヒダができるとそういった実現することができました
でファブカフェ枚がある一台のことを少し紹介します
枚はぎふてんの一番北側ですね
北側にありましてとなりから行くとなんだかんだで5時間以上かかるって事多い場所に
あります
弟子の面積の97%はこういった
森に追われています
街並みは
東古川町というところが僕らの拠点なんですけれども
咲か蔵の白い壁があって
で声が泳いでいる瀬戸川という川が流れている
景色が美しいことでま有名な街です
春になると
なんかソウルをすごい感じるんだよねっていうアーティストがよそからも続々とやって
くるような
古川まつりという祭りがありまして起し太鼓という大きな
荘厳な太鼓とわーっとつける好やんちゃな
つけないこと言う若い衆がまあ一晩中まちじゅうを練り歩くというそういった祭りが
あるような場所です
一方で膝の産業の方に目を向けてみると先ほどの97%を占めている
守りを基点とした林業だったりとか
製材業だったり大工さんがいて核づくりがあってそれらが高いレベルで動いていて産業
の循環をつくっている割と高豊かな人間のあるそういった街だなというのが大事
ショーでした
レースでにそういった綺麗な循環がある街の中では僕らが何に挑戦しているかといえば
もう一度その伝統的な技術と言われている大工さんの技だったり各職人の技をもう一度
見つめ直したり木という素材にもう一度向き合ってみたりしてそれらをまた別の
アイディアとまぁ1種配合することそういったことを僕らはを行う
ていますその中から既存の循環から
ぴょんと飛び出した新しいものを作る
そういった新しいものづくりにチャレンジするのが僕らの役割になっています
ぜひだの森の特徴はえーっと
昨日話ばっかりしてますが建築の材料は針葉樹定期です
飛騨の森に多いのは針葉樹ではなくて
広葉樹あの桜とかどんぐりがなる木とか入った木ですね
でそれらは少し硬くて他の材料になるんですけれどもえーっとそういった広葉樹は
世界中に20万以上あると実は言われていて一つ一つがすごいユニークな
大寒だったり性質を持っていてまっクリエイティブのたい衝動にすぐには非常に魅力的
な素材だと思っています
でこれを
全部立派のためになればいいんですけどもなかなか
は多種多様な工業地であるがゆえにえっとそれらが全部立派な角になるとは限らないと
そういった実情を見て
k 覗い機だったりとか曲がりくねった秋だったりとかそういったものももっと輝ける
家具になれなくても輝ける場所が見せ場があるんじゃないかと
そういった思えたら
例えば建築がだったりとか
デザイナーだったり気を使って何か新しいプロダクトを作ってみたいそういったことを
考えている企業の人だったりとかそういった人にみんなは続々と枚に来てもらい一緒に
森を歩き
一緒に製剤中に行き職人さんの意味の職人さんの話に耳を傾けたりそういったことを
知って
皆さんに聴いに取り組むきっかけをつかんでもらうそういったことをしています
家具でもまだまだできることはたくさんあると思っているのですが
えっとここでは2つだけですけどと書く以外のあるとことになった事例を紹介します
一つ目が猫と
猫と暮らす人その人たちのためのプロダクトです
最初僕のところにやってきた相談は
100万円のキャットたーーーーを発売したいんだよねっていうわりと高無茶ぶりなぁ
感じの相談がやってきました
キャットタワーってまあ買おうと思えば1万以下でも売っているようなそういったもの
を生んだけどそれを敢えて100万円で作りたいとそのなんか
強い信念にちょっと心打たれてワクワクするなぁと思って取り組んでみようということ
になりました
レーマーこの時は建築設計をしてきた時以来
まあいろんなディティールをかきつつそのクライアントとデザイナーの方そして
えっと枚の職人さんの前あらゆる技術を統合することに努めました
で100万円の価値のあるまあキャットタワーを奪って作ろうかなっていう時に
もちろんその素晴らしい技術と素晴らしい素材の掛け合わせ
統合というのはもちろん大切なんですけどもそこにやっぱりストーリーを統合したいな
と思いましたその時に兄の遅い
機であっても実はその桔平森の中では100年以上の歴史
思ってたりとかで多種多様な森の様相がそのままプロダクトに落ちてくるそういった
デザインにしていくことで
期のストーリーそのものが
このプロダクトの価値になるのではないかと考えました
そうして生まれたのがこのキャットタワーです
二つ目のプロジェクトなんですけども越冬一件は地味なんですがこれ
静大上の工程をじっくり観察した時にたくさんこうなんでしょう機の破片北方が出て
くるですねその国家も
先ほど言ったように100年以上本当は森にあったんだけどなんかポンポンせられて
しまうとそういったものももう一度その見せ場を作れないかなと思って考えたのが
えっとチップボードでした
で先ほどのキャットタワーがまあ一品物のアートワークのようなものだったとしたら
こちらはもうどんどんバンバン使ってくださいっていうようなまぁ建材になるような
そういったボードです
でそれで生まれたのがこのチップボードで例えばこの緑色の部分なんかは
えっとしたのの伝統的な何でしょう郷土料理のほうば味噌というのがあるんですけども
その葉っぱのがなる方法
朴木と勇気を原料になってますでこれが磨くとにがいてコート層をしてあげるとすごい
石のような大理石のような綺麗な質感になっ
でまぁそれがえっと建築家の方にも評判で今実際にこれは採用されるプロジェクトが
動いてます
そんな感じでえっと
あらゆる技術をつなぐ人アーキテクトの役割を果たすためには
常に目の前に起こっているいろんな状況に対して常に高オープンな思考でいることが
大切です
まあすごい単純なことなんですけれども意外と常に意識するのは難しくて
越冬
経験を積めば積むほどあり渡航経験ニトロ勝手がちになってしまって知らず知らずの
うちにそれが自分の考えであることを忘れてしまって誰かに押し付けようとしてしまっ
たりそういったことをまあしがちかなと思います
で常にオープンな考え抜いて目の前で起こることを大切にする
例目の前で話しているクルー方の意見だったりとかアイディアやそういったものを全て
埋めを凝らしてみよう傾けて拾い上げてそれらをはるか昔の技術から現代の技術まで
いろんな引き出しから引っ張ってきてそれらを統合
をする人それが僕が思う
アーキテクトぞーかなと思います
で開く真の皆には全員こうアーキテクト増のこのアーキテクトになってほしいなという
ふうな思いがあってえっと開く真の家訓というものを作ったのでこれを最後にみなさん
に紹介して終わりにしたいと思います
開くマカくん第1条北木しない
僕も気しないという意味は
まあ気を生かしてあげる新しい見方で機を生かしてあげるためには常に新しい素材た
ような他の素材との組み合わせにチャレンジすること
第2条悪口は言わない
そういった想いはぐっとこらえて悪口を口に出すことはまあ空気を汚すことであると
なので悪口は絶対言わないようにしよう
第3条は同時に始まり掃除に追われる
綺麗な仕事場から
黄色い綺麗で機動的なプロダクトが生まれるって言うのはまぁ当たり前なんですけども
普段全然その意識が出なかった部屋の隅々までまあ観察して小さな発見でもいいから
日々の発見を大切にしよう
そういうことです
第4条は無理と言わない
誰も無理っていうことを聞きたくないと本当はこれをやりたいと思ってるんだけども
どうしたらいい
そういったことに対して常に可能性があることを可能性についての話をしようと
で実現するための遅延をみんなでだ4 k
第5条が相談されたら必ず相談に乗る
自分がそのプロジェクトの担当ではないですとか
自分がその分野の専門外ですとかそういったことはもう一切関係ない
関係なくてせっかく相談してくれたその人ときちんと向き合って一緒に考えて相談され
た人が次にどうしたらいいかだわかるようにちゃんとその次のアクションを与えて
あげること
でそして
相談された人は責任と強い意志を持って必ずそれを実現させるために動くこと
これを大切にしてくださいというのが開く真の
架空になります
以上
です
あのあっていくとになろうという
ことを少しでも心に留めつつ皆さん
とにかく挑戦してみるそれに祈ってくれたら嬉しいなぁと思いますありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
[拍手]